uh we have yet another data point
in which we find that while claiming
that the left was censoring the right on
Twitter and elsewhere the Trump
Administration was demanding others be
censored so let me back up a little bit
as we start to talk about this story
during the first I guess the first
couple days of hearings about
the weaponization of big Tech or
whatever it was we learned we learned
that the Trump Administration wanted
celebrity Chrissy Teigen
um uh censored for an insult she made
about President Donald Trump let me
remind you we this remember these were
hearings meant to make the left look bad
and they made the right look like
triggered snowflakes
um Miss uh uh niravoli earlier you
testified about a 2019 tweet yeah
um that was about President Trump and I
think it's from Miss Teigen what was the
Tweet about yeah
would you like me to give the direct
quote yeah
um please excuse my language this is a
direct quote but Chrissy Teigen referred
to Donald Trump as a ass
okay
free speech and what happened after Miss
Teigen posted her tweet what did the
White House do what did the Trump White
House do right from my understanding the
White House reached out to ask that this
tweet be removed it was my team's uh job
this fell underneath the policy for
abusive behaviors and we evaluate it
underneath our insults policy at that
time up to three insults were allowed
and so it was our job to determine how
many insults were included within that
phrase White House reached out not an
agency but the White House reached out
and requested that you remove the the
tweet from my understanding yes okay so
the story that they were telling on the
right is it's the left that constantly
wants to do censorship and blah blah
blah blah blah a celebrity insults Trump
and they try to get the Tweet deleted
but we now know that that's not the only
such example we have also now learned uh
that the Trump White House was
pressuring Disney meaning ABC to censor
Jimmy Kimmel this is uh
at this point are we surprised by this
at all Rolling Stone article the former
president was so incensed by the late
night host Jimmy Kimmel making fun of
him that he had his staff take action
this was in early 2018
um The American National Security
apparatus was fixated on reports that
North Korea was building nuclear weapons
which could reach the U.S or that Russia
was plotting chemical weapons
assassinations in Europe Trump meanwhile
was busy targeting his idea of An Enemy
of the State late night host Jimmy
Kimmel according to two former Trump
Administration officials Trump was so
upset by Jimmy Kimmel's comedic Jabs
that he directed White House staff to
call up one of Disney's top Executives
in DC to complain and demand action ABC
is owned by Disney in at least two
separate phone calls that occurred
around the time Trump was finishing his
first year in office the White House
conveyed the severity of Trump's Fury
with Kimmel to Disney Trump's staff
mentioned the leader of the Free World
wanted the billion dollar company to
reign in Jimmy Kimmel for trashing Trump
and Trump felt that Kimmel had in the
characterization of a former
Administration official been very
dishonest and doing things that Trump
would have sued over
the incident was so bizarre and use of
it spread around the corridors of power
in DC other Administration officials who
had nothing to do with the pressure
campaign expressed they were confused
that the white that they expressed
hearing from Disney that they were
confused that the White House was
telling them Trump wants to tone down
the humor they
are the triggered snowflakes and I know
we've said it so many times before
accusations or confessions and its
projection and all of these different
things
it really is the truth and from the
Twitter files we learned basically that
the Trump administration had the same
access if that's what you want to call
it to request things be removed as the
Biden campaign remember Trump
Administration Biden campaign and from
all of these anecdotes we're learning
that the Trump White House was regularly
trying to use their powers of censorship
while claiming that it is the left that
was trying to censor them it is yet
another case where the truth is the
opposite of what they tell us I am sure
these two examples that we mentioned
today aren't the only ones
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below